und das stimmt olaf scholz ist bei uns
finanzminister und kanzlerkandidat der
spd der abend ist noch jung vor allem
was die zahlen angeht was ist ihr
zwischenzeitliches fazit dieser
bundestagswahl die bürger nur bürger
haben eine klare botschaft hinterlassen
sie wollen dass die sozialdemokratischen
partei eine regierung bildet und man
sieht es daran einfach dass die balken
ordentlich nach oben gegangen sind die
in den grafiken gezeigt wurden das ist
etwas was mich sehr bewegt aber mir auch
die verantwortung auffällig das zu tun
was jetzt erwartet wenn ihr den auftrag
ehrlich gesagt wie ganz so eindeutig
ersichtlich weil die zahlen sowohl für
union als auch für die spd noch relativ
dicht beieinander liegen stand jetzt
bald darauf war der einen wagen ziemlich
runter war der anderen ist eine aussage
die die bürgerinnen bürger getroffen
haben das wird auch beim
regierungsbildung eine rolle spielen
müssen aber entscheiden wird der im
unterm strich dann sein wer die nase
vorne hat und das ist noch nicht so
richtig ersichtlich im augenblick sind
wir sehr froh über das was wir hier
sehen können und ich finde das
entspricht auch der stimmung die ich auf
vielen marktplätzen an vielen treffen
gespräch mit vielen bürgern und bürgern
wahrgenommen habe die wollen jetzt nicht
ein aufbruch in die zwanziger jahre
dieses schaffen für mehr respekt zu
sorgen in unserer gesellschaft wie wir
dafür sorge tragen kann dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung unseres
landes hin bekommen und dass wir es
schaffen den menschengemachten klima
aufzuhalten sie beanspruchten die
regierungsbildung auch armin laschet hat
sich schon entsprechend geäußert und
will eine bürgerliche regierung bilden
was erwidern sie ihm noch mal die
bürgerinnen und bürger haben gesprochen
sie haben ziemlich klar gemacht was sie
sich wünschen das sieht man an der
richtung der alten die bei einigen
parteien nach oben gegangen sind aber
insbesondere bei einer ziemlich nach
oben was hat den ausschlag gegeben ihrer
meinung nach dass die spd wieder so gut
dasteht wie zuletzt vor ich glaube zwei
bundestagswahlen oder sogar besser
das ist sicher die tatsache dass wir ein
sehr zuversichtliches pragmatisches
programm
vorgestellt haben das genau die aufgabe
nennt vor denen unser land wirklich
stetig haben schon genannt respekt
industrielle modernisierung
menschengemachte klimawandel und das
auch dafür sorgt dass das wird nicht
funktioniert denn wenn die weichen jetzt
falsch gestellt werden dann können wir
vielleicht in vier acht oder zwölf
jahren das nicht mehr korrigieren sie
haben eben bundestagswahlkampf
gelegentlich gesagt dass sie gerne mit
den grünen regieren würden das wird
nicht reichen gibt es mittlerweile jetzt
wo der wahlkampf jetzt zu ende ist und
auch die ersten ergebnisse eintrudeln
und das ganze ein bisschen greifbarer
wird ein bisschen mehr klarheit mit wem
sie denn dann diese künftige regierung
bilden wollen aus meiner sicht gucken
wir jetzt mal wie es endgültig ausgeht
und dann werden wir das tun was die
wähler und satz auftrag hinterlassen
haben und daran werde ich mich auch
orientieren dann bedanke mich an dieser
stelle denn ich bin sicher dass ich an
dieser stelle nicht film herauskriegen
würde herzlichen dank olaf scholz
und bei uns geht es weiter im wahlstudio